bonjour a tous invités de sao galice
matériel dsk bonjour bonjour bonjour de
70 spectateurs de martinique 1ère vous
êtes membre du comité de soutien hier
françois fillon qui a remporté la
primaire de la droite et du centre
martinique également françois fillon
fillon bardon a gagné il a renversé la
vapeur alors qu'au premier tour était
alain juppé qui l'avait emporté au
second tour la tendance s'est inversée
et françois fillon a gagné avec 850 voix
d'écart avec alain juppé comment
expliquez-vous ce revirement uniquement
le report des voix alors tout d'abord
avant de répondre à votre question
j'aimerais remercier les 4300 26 votants
en martinique en particulier les 2683
électeurs qui ont voté à les français
françois fillon pardon non je ne pense
pas que ce soit par des voies moi je
pense que les gens ont adhéré au
programme marie thé dans un bureau par
exemple j'ai constaté qu'il ya un
renouvellement des personnes qui ont
fréquenté ce bureau donc ce n'est pas
forcément les mêmes personnes qui ont
voté au premier tour qui sont deuxièmes
tôt pas de report de voix des
sarkozystes et puis oui il peut y avoir
des sacs aux skis ont voté françois
fillon mais je veux dire que ce n'est
pas principalement
principalement les votants c'est
principalement la cause de ce
reversement
donc il y à de nouvelles adhésions au
test de filles ont six à huit grammes
selon lui à de nouvelles adhésions
programme de fillon et puis vous savez
françois fillon est un homme intègre et
il a fait face à certaines critiques et
les gens je pense on commence à en avoir
marre des critiques au point de vue
politique sur la scène alors qu'elle
donne à voter pour votre candidat on en
parle de la martinique dans quelles
zones géographiques exactement il a eu
beaucoup de voix dans pas mal de
communes comme lerobert com
sur cher comme fort de france 3 90%
comment vous expliquer également
françois mais parce que vous avez les
gens sont libres mais il faut dix ont
fait leur choix donc peut-être plus aux
france 3 que de deux endroits mais il
faut dire que la participation à
certains endroits sont sont plus
minimales peut-être que des gens ne sont
pas venus voter aimeraient ils sont pas
venus voter pour x raisons mais je pense
que si globalement martinique le
programme de fillon et tient à des rires
un bouddha population dans l'hexagone
françois fillon devra décider s'il garde
ou pas la direction actuelle des
républicains qui était pour sarkozy est
ce que la question se pose dans les
mêmes termes ici avec la tête des
républicains qui étaient des
républicains qui a soutenu alain juppé
il faut la changer jusqu'à maintenant
non non non nous sommes dans une optique
plutôt de mobilisation parce
qu'effectivement nous étions en campagne
c'est une primaire mais à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui il faut unifier les forces
il faut mobiliser et je pense que c'est
plutôt dans cette optique que nous irons
quand elle disait je marque parti dans
son édito la présidentielle sera
l'occasion de reconstruire une droite
unifiée oui oui bien de bien évidemment
parce que vous avez la droite a été
dernièrement effectivement un peu divisé
mais maintenant que nous avons choisi
notre leader forcément cette droite sera
unifié est ce que avec cette victoire ça
ne donne pas des ailes ou fillonniste en
martinique
dl oui parce que par exemple pour il ya
quand même une dynamique qui s'est dit
là mais qu'il faut savoir d'ailleurs je
tiens à remercier parce que nous avons
notre équipe parce que nous avons une
petite équipe dynamique et pourquoi je
les remercie parce que ce soit des gens
qu'il était convaincu et qui ont
démontré à qu'avec des convictions on
soulève démontrer oui d'allier mais pour
répondre à votre question
non je pense pas que ça donne dizaine
moi je pense plus que ça va donner une
nouvelle dynamique comme je vous ai dit
de mobilisation c'est derrière john
montrose qui a montré qu'elle était une
chaîne politique efficace et voilà moi
c'est on ne songeait pas il ya à
profiter de cette dynamique justement
lancé par par cette primaire par exemple
on voit pour les élections législatives
de 2010 est qu'il ya un certain nombre
de candidats républicains karine
mousseau dans le centre atlantique
soutien de nicolas sarkozy
il ya mon plaisir peut-être dans le nord
peut-être dans le sud ça en attend
encore peut-être dans le sud du fred
michel tir au soutien d'alain juppé mais
quelle aventure fort de france et dans
tout ce beau monde il n'y a aucun
représentant de françois fillon faudrait
peut-être profiter de cette dynamique
pour l'instant jeannie nature je pense
que notre optique pour le moment c'est
les présidentielles notre objectif c'est
que françois fillon soit président on
n'a pas encore réfléchi à ce genre de
stratégie je pense qu'on n'est pas dans
l'optique de faire de la stratégie pour
faire de la stratégie nous nous sommes
vraiment des présidentielles on croit en
notre candidat et nous voulons nous
voulons qu'il soit président mais
président après ça appelle peut être à
d'autres
ambition
ou le jour au lendemain je ne vois pas
du jour au lendemain vous labeaume on
n'en a pas encore discuté donc je peux
pas vous dire et verse mais n'ont
d'autres objectifs à l'heure actuelle
c'est que notre président que nos
présidences mois françois fillon en 2017
alors nous allons parler du programme
maintenant de françois fillon mais avant
tout vous avez 24 ans voilà et pour vous
êtes étudiant et pour françois fillon
représente la droite moderne droite
progressiste à lembras ouvert françois
fillon pour moi effectivement est une
nouvelle droite parce qu'il peut les
projets qu'ils proposent à particulier
pour l'outre-mer on va développer je
passe par la suite font que à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je pense que c'est l'homme
qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui c'est la
modernité françois fillon mais bien sûr
écouter quels quel candidat proposé de
créer une allocation sociale unique pour
centraliser les aides sociales pour
éviter aux martiniquais d'aller à la
cave de par les embouteillages dans
l'air pour l'emploi et d'aller dans
d'autres instances pour obtenir des
aides qu'elle quels candidats
formés père qu'elle propose de créer un
conseil conseil conseil que titre
consultatif de l'outre-mer pour
permettre justement qu'avant le la
première application des lois il ya une
consultation d'outre-mer moi je sais
qu'à trois roses la la suppression de
500 emplois des fonctionnaires
il faut s'attendre aussi à des
suppressions d'emplois en martinique
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de champions
attention moi je parle plutôt de
réduction d'emplois parce que lui l'a
prévu il a pris cinq cent mille emplois
cinq cent mille emplois sur cinq ans en
sachant qu'il ya 120 milles départ à la
retraite donc ce qui fait effectivement
s'il ya autant de contractuels qui nous
rend il ya un bilan plus contre achat
qualifiant qui ont envie de centrales
totalisant même 140 milles de manoeuvre
ou embaucher au niveau de la fonction
publique n'est qu'en cinq ans 120000
contractuels ça fait quand même des
personnes qui resteront sur le carreau
oui mais quand on rajoute les 120000
contractuels et les 120 milles départ à
la retraite ça nous fait deux cent
quarante mille si on arrive économiser
100 mille par an de toutes les façons
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à opérer
par le seul état à embaucher 5,7
millions de fonctionnaires sans en avoir
les moyens
ça c'est clair
donc forcément il faut prendre des
mesures il faut les prendre dès
aujourd'hui
concernant la santé françois fillon
propose de supprimer le tiers payant et
de focaliser l'assurance publique
universelle c'est d'adil universel par
donc c'est à dire la sécurité sociale
sur les affections graves ou de longue
durée et les assurances privées
s'occuperont des autres c'est désormais
il faut soit avoir un cancer une maladie
grave être diabétiques ou hypertendus
pour être remboursé c'est ça non enfin
non mais c'est ce qu'écrit façon
appuyons prévoit pour les personnes ça
dépend des situations passant pour moi
prévoir où les personnes quelle pauvreté
effectivement des adaptations par
rapport à ça mais c'est quand même ce
qui est écrit c'est que maintenant c'est
une est-ce que c'est pas comment te dire
comment vous dire une
santé à deux vitesses qui sacrera créé
par non pas sa figurine en complément de
mettre en place une équité fois la
différence inéquité c'est à dieu qu'il
l'aide à fait là ils aident il est tout
le monde mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que les personnes en deuil
nouveautés au bon bénéficier de moyens
de système mais par contre j'aimerais
revenir sous les brumes dans les filles
aux sur l'outre-mer si ça ne vous
dérange pas ça je pense que c'est ce qui
est important au niveau des partisans
mais la santé 1 par oui oui je vous ai
déjà expliqué effectivement que des
personnes qui sont enfin pauvreté pour
bénéficier de ce qui est ce qu'ils ne
sont pas donc on devra payer
l'installation ça existera toujours pour
les personnes d'affections graves non du
tout c'est ce qui manquait
non oui c'est ça qui est écrit mais non
du tout c'est que les gens bénéficieront
les gens de mode modeste bénéficions de
moyens pour se soigner alors voulais
absolument partir on a très peu de temps
de deux parce que ce n'était pas tant
parce que c'est un aspect que les gens
n'ont pas vu devant la campagne fillon
n'ont pas entendu dans les médias parce
que françois fillon un objectif
l'outre-mer c'est d'abord valoriser nos
atouts nous at on assuré dans
particulier et là je voulais prendre
trois axes avec vous qui est d'abord
l'agriculture en a très peu et déjà 29
ans donc l'agriculture en tout cas le
showbiz des énergies renouvelables ce
sont les grands axes des grands hommes
les loisirs ou pays vont développer en
outre mer en outre-mer yann descat je
vous remercie merci d'avoir participé à
sao cadix en qualité à mener